Oh, it's been lovely. This is like, it's a three-day conference and it's the third day and I'm not completely sick of it yet. And nobody else is either, which is unusual for conferences these days. I remember going to my first conference. I remember how scared I was. I didn't know how any of it worked. And the more welcoming we can be and the more we can make everything make sense to everybody, that's going to naturally give us more speakers, more organizers, more volunteers, more everything, as well as more attendees. Some human, I think it was Matt Godbolt said today. Some human. That is a great description of Matt Godbolt. Some human. My name's Kristen. I work on the C++ Libraries team at Google. We like to think of ourselves as like the stewards of the C++ portion of the code.
哦，真是太棒了。这就像是，这是一个为期三天的会议，现在已经是第三天了，而我还没有完全对它感到厌烦。而且其他人也没有，这在如今的会议中是很少见的。我记得我去参加我的第一次会议时。我记得当时我是多么害怕。我不知道这一切是如何运作的。我们越是热情好客，越是能让每件事对每个人都通俗易懂，这自然会给我们带来更多的演讲者、更多的组织者、更多的志愿者、更多的一切，以及更多的参会者。某个凡人，我想是马特·戈德堡（Matt Godbolt）今天说的。某个凡人。对马特·戈德堡来说，这是个极好的描述。某个凡人。我叫克里斯滕（Kristen）。我在谷歌的 C++ 库团队工作。我们喜欢把自己看作是代码中 C++ 部分的管家。
The very ending of my keynote was actually a callback to how Mike opened the conference on Monday. He said, patience,1, recorded on July 19th, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Ben Dean, we record live from CPP North 2023 in Toronto, Canada, and talk to speakers and attendees. Today we speak to Kate Gregory, Kristen Shaker, and Jessica Kerr. We're going to hand the mic to Ben, who's going to interview Kate Gregory, who has been on the podcast once. I think it was turned into four episodes, and you were recording from your cabin at the time, but handing the mic over to Ben, who's going to interview Kate. Hi, Kate. So you're one of the board members here at CPP North. How is that going?
我的主题演讲的最后部分实际上呼应了迈克（Mike）周一开幕时的致辞。他说，耐心，1，录制于2023年7月19日。我叫康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人本·迪恩（Ben Dean）一起，在加拿大多伦多的 2023 年 C++ 北方大会（CPP North 2023）上进行现场录制，并与演讲者和参会者进行交流。今天我们的访谈嘉宾有凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）、克里斯滕·谢克（Kristen Shaker）和杰西卡·克尔（Jessica Kerr）。我们要把麦克风交给本，他将采访凯特·格雷戈里，凯特曾上过一次播客。我想那是被剪成了四集，当时你是在你的小木屋里进行录制的，不过现在就把麦克风交给本，他将采访凯特。嗨，凯特。所以你是这里 C++ 北方大会的董事会成员之一。进展得怎么样？
Oh, so much better today. Thank you. We just announced a very large sponsor, made us very happy. We have a gold sponsor. Boy, is it ever hard work to run a conference. Last year, we didn't know how to run a conference. So we thought this year would be easier. This year was harder because we knew what we were doing was much harder. But we made a conference. I'm so happy, so happy with this program and people. Well, it certainly has been and continues to be a fantastic conference. It's been wonderful being here.
哦，今天好多了。谢谢。我们刚刚宣布了一家非常大的赞助商，这让我们非常高兴。我们有了一个黄金赞助商。天哪，办一场会议真是太辛苦了。去年，我们不知道怎么办会议。所以我们以为今年会更容易。今年更难，因为我们知道我们在做什么，这要难得多。但我们成功办成了一场会议。我太高兴了，对这个节目和大家感到非常高兴。嗯，这确实是一场，并且将继续是一场精彩绝伦的会议。能来到这里真是太棒了。
You're an experienced keynote speaker at this point. So how do you come up with a new idea for a keynote, especially at your home conference? So yeah, that was a challenge. The atmosphere here is different. The keynote that I did here last year, I couldn't have done anywhere else. I feel like here I can reach out a little different topic area. So I was struggling with what was I going to talk about? And I had one idea in my head. And my husband, bless him, he came into the room to show me a way cool thing that had just come in the mail. A little tool.
到目前为止，你已经是一位经验丰富的主题演讲者了。那么，你是如何为主题演讲想出一个新创意的，尤其是在你的主场会议上？所以，是的，这是一个挑战。这里的氛围不同。我去年在这里做的主题演讲，在其他任何地方都做不了。我觉得在这里我可以涉足稍微不同的主题领域。所以我一直在纠结我要讲什么？我脑子里有一个想法。然后我丈夫，愿上帝保佑他，他走进房间给我看了一件刚刚收到邮件的超级酷的东西。一个小工具。
And I loved this little tool. And I thought, oh, that goes in my keynote. And I wrote my keynote. And then I actually ended up dropping the section about tools from it, which is a shame. But that was my inspiration. The idea of life as a journey and having good tools and having the things you need to get along the way. Yeah. Cool. What would you say to any people out there who haven't thought maybe about speaking, but maybe we could
我非常喜欢这个小工具。我想，哦，这个可以放进我的主题演讲里。然后我写了我的主题演讲。最后我实际上删掉了里面关于工具的那一部分，这挺遗憾的。但这就是我的灵感。把生活当作一场旅程，拥有好的工具，拥有沿途所需的东西。是的。酷。你会对外面那些可能还没考虑过演讲，但也许我们可以
convince them to take up speaking? What would you say to them about the process of coming up with ideas and making a talk and coming to a conference? Oh should first of all like no matter no matter what it takes to be able to get you to do it you should do it because it's it's life-changing yeah you don't really understand a topic until you try to explain it and i encourage people when they do a first talk to do something that really matters to them so like someone else can do what's new in c++ 26 or whatever there'll be a big lineup of people to do that. But if you were like, we decided to get right with const in our code or with const expert in our code, and here's what happened. That's a great talk. I want to hear
说服他们走上演讲台的人说些什么呢？关于构思创意、制作演讲以及参加会议的过程，你会对他们说些什么？哦，首先，不管需要付出什么代价才能让你去这样做，你都应该去做，因为它能改变人生。是的，在你试图解释一个话题之前，你并不真正理解它。我鼓励人们在做第一次演讲时，去做那些对他们真正重要的事情。所以，其他人可能会讲 C++ 26 有什么新变化之类的内容，会有很多人排队去做这个。但如果你想的是，我们决定在代码中搞清楚 const 的用法，或者在代码中搞清楚 constexpr 的用法，结果是这样的。那真是一场棒极了的演讲。我想听
that talk because you care about it. Absolutely. Yeah, I would echo that you don't need to be an expert to be a speaker either. Like the valuable talk can be, here's the journey of how I discovered this, right? Absolutely. And even if it didn't work sometimes, you know? So we had a lightning talk last night that ended with, you know, to be continued. They didn't have a conclusion yet.
那场演讲，因为你在乎它。绝对的。是的，我呼应你的观点，你不需要成为专家才能成为演讲者。有价值的演讲也可以是，这是我发现这一点的旅程，对吧？绝对是的。甚至有时它没有成功，你知道吗？所以我们昨晚有一个闪电演讲，以“未完待续”结束。他们还没有得出结论。
That's okay. That's still valuable. I'll add too that it's been amazing to see during the lightning talks. I think it was two volunteers, Emily and Jeremy, who hopefully we can find at some point today to chat with them. I could be wrong. I mean, they seem like they were experienced speakers, but I've never seen them give talks at C++ conferences. I think the lightning talk you were just referring to was Diana's first talk. And I was poking her like, are you going to give a 60 minute follow up next year? And we talked to Vincent Zalzal. So it seems like there's...
没关系。那仍然很有价值。我还要补充的是，在闪电演讲期间看到这一幕真是太惊人了。我想是两位志愿者，艾米莉（Emily）和杰里米（Jeremy），希望我们今天能在某个时候找到他们聊聊。我也许记错了。我的意思是，他们看起来像是经验丰富的演讲者，但我从未见过他们在 C++ 会议上发表演讲。我想你刚刚提到的闪电演讲是黛安娜（Diana）的第一次演讲。我在旁边怂恿她，问她明年是不是要做一个 60 分钟的后续演讲？我们和文森特·扎尔扎尔（Vincent Zalzal）聊过。所以看起来……
Vincent's first talk. Yeah. Vincent's first conference and first talk is right here at CPP North. And that talk, I'm in the back going, I would give this talk. So the talk I would give them, that's better. I would not have done that part. And that's fantastic. Hey, he's doing my talk that I didn't write better than I would have written it. Like it was very good. And then someone said, this is his first talk. Oh, that's impressive. Yeah. And there's, I won't name names of other conferences, but definitely there are certain conferences where their sort of mission statement is we want to give the best experience, which means they're less interested in trying to find new voices
文森特的第一次演讲。是的。文森特的第一次会议和第一次演讲就在 C++ 北方大会。那场演讲，我在后排心里想，我也会做这个演讲。所以我要给他们的演讲，那样更好。我不会做那一部分的。这太棒了。嘿，他把我没写出来的演讲做得比我写得还要好。感觉非常棒。然后有人说，这是他的第一次演讲。哦，这太令人印象深刻了。是的。而且，我不会点名其他会议，但肯定有些会议，他们的某种使命宣言是“我们想要提供最好的体验”，这意味着他们对寻找新声音
and take risks on new speakers. And I know that one of our missions, I'm no longer involved in organizing, but I was last year, was trying to take risks on new speakers because we see a lot of the times at other conferences, like I think there was something on Twitter where there was a shot of the front row and it was like 90% the same front row as it was at C++ on C last week, which is great because a lot of people love listening to speakers that they know. But I love like finding new speakers like, you know, when you see someone new and you have no idea, are they going to be like super confident? And those lightning talks were like, I was like, these volunteers need to be like, you know know giving full 60 minute talks next year because
以及对新演讲者进行冒险的兴趣较小。我知道我们的使命之一——我不再参与组织工作，但我去年参与了——就是尝试对新演讲者进行冒险，因为我们看到很多时候在其他会议上，我想推特上有一张前排的照片，大约 90% 的前排面孔和上周在 C++ Now 会议上的前排是一样的，这很好，因为很多人喜欢听他们认识的演讲者演讲。但我喜欢寻找新的演讲者，就像，你知道，当你看到一个新人时，你根本不知道，他们会超级自信吗？那些闪电演讲让我觉得，这些志愿者明年一定要做那种，你知道的，完整的 60 分钟演讲，因为
like especially like they seemed a bit younger i'm assuming i know emily mentioned i believe she was in third year university and still has a couple like at that level if they're already that good like imagine the kind of talks they're going to be giving in you know five years if they continue at it so i was just like super awesome to see like new voices and uh people that you know first time conferences just fantastic because I know that was a mission of this conference. So it seems like, you know, this is the second year and we're already starting to see that pay dividends. We really are. And, you know, I have a talk I haven't been able to find home for partly because whenever I do it, it's three hours long. So I have
特别是像他们看起来稍微年轻一些，我假设，我记得艾米莉提到过，我相信她读大三，在那个水平上如果他们已经这么优秀了，想象一下他们在（你知道的）五年后会做什么样的演讲，如果他们继续坚持下去的话。所以我只是觉得看到新声音和那些第一次参加会议的人真是太棒了，因为我知道那是这次会议的使命。所以看起来，（你知道的）这是第二年，我们已经开始看到回报了。确实如此。而且，（你知道的）我有一个演讲一直没能找到合适的平台，部分原因是一旦我做这个演讲，就会长达三个小时。所以我得
to make it shorter before I can find that a home, but it's about how to have a more diverse set of speakers. There's 11 main bullets. 10 of them are about having more diverse attendees. Because that's where we're going to grow your speakers from. So you be welcoming. You be a place that people feel okay to come. I remember going to my first conference. I remember how scared I was. I didn't know how any of it worked.
在为它找到平台之前把它缩短，但它是关于如何拥有更多样化的演讲者阵容的。其中有 11 个主要要点。其中 10 个是关于拥有更多样化的参会者的。因为那是我们培养演讲者的土壤。所以你要保持热情好客。你要成为一个让人们觉得来这里很舒服的地方。我还记得我去参加第一次会议的时候。我记得我是多么害怕。我不知道这一切是如何运作的。
I literally didn't even really understand how convention centers and hotels worked, you know. And the more welcoming we can be and the more we can make everything make sense to everybody, that's going to naturally give us more speakers, more organizers, more volunteers, more everything, as well as more attendees. Yeah. And I would say to folks out there, if there's a talk that you want to watch on youtube the best way to affect that is to give that talk that's how i started one of the things i love about conferences is you know how the talks evolve during the conference from having seen other talks like your talk your keynote kate was fantastic and you gave me the phrase, you know,
我甚至字面意思上都不太理解会议中心和酒店是如何运作的，你知道的。我们越是热情好客，越是能让每件事对每个人都通俗易懂，这自然会给我们带来更多的演讲者、更多的组织者、更多的志愿者、更多的一切，以及更多的参会者。是的。我想对大家说，如果你在 YouTube 上有一场想看的演讲，实现这一点的最佳方式就是去做那场演讲。这就是我开始的方式。我喜欢会议的一点是，你知道演讲在会议期间是如何演变的，通过看过其他演讲，比如你的演讲，凯特，你的主题演讲太棒了，你给了我一句话，你知道的，
this should work. I saw that for the first time. It might have been the first CPPCon where Chandler and Andre were alternating. They gave multiple talks and they were quoting each other back and forth. I've never been an edit my slide on the day person, but I'm thrilled when people do it. I love seeing a callback to something we just experienced yeah it's great yeah i'll mention too like we were talking to tristan who we interviewed yesterday and he gave us the same version of a talk that he's giving in t minus something came up on my watch nine minutes from now and he gave it like a couple weeks ago or three weeks ago at c++ on C. But that was the first time he was giving that talk there. And so obviously there's no other talks mentioning it or the library because it hasn't really been announced. I think technically
这应该行得通。我是第一次看到那个。那可能是第一届 C++ 大会（CPPCon），钱德勒（Chandler）和安德烈（Andrei）轮流登场。他们做了多次演讲，并且互相引用对方的话。我从来都不是那种在当天修改幻灯片的人，但当别人这么做时，我感到非常兴奋。我喜欢看到对我们刚刚经历的事情的回呼。是的，这太棒了。是的，我还要提一下，就像我们和昨天采访过的特里斯坦（Tristan）谈过的那样，他带来了他在倒计时——我手表上跳出来某个东西，从现在起九分钟后——要做的那个演讲的相同版本，而他几周前或三周前才在 C++ Now 会议上讲过。但那是他第一次在那里做那个演讲。所以显然没有其他演讲提到它或这个库，因为它还没有真正宣布。我想严格来说
he talked about it on a podcast. But now at this conference, I think there's been three talks already that have like referred to the library that he's, you know, talking about. So it's, if you are an avid talk watcher, it's very cool to see like, you know, one talk influencing other talks and the keynotes are basically all referring back to like the previous keynotes. And anyways, it's, it's super cool. You know, you have to watch them all and it's a little bit easier. I think if you're at the conference, cause you're seeing stuff chronologically happen. But if you're watching this on YouTube later, you might be able to pick up on, I mean, my favorite was when I saw Stefan Labowate.
他在一个播客上谈论过它。但现在在这场会议上，我认为已经有三个演讲提到了他（你知道的）正在谈论的那个库。所以，如果你是一个狂热的演讲观看者，看到一个演讲影响其他演讲，这真的很酷，而且主题演讲基本上都在回顾之前的主题演讲。不管怎样，这超级酷。你知道，你必须把它们都看完，而且如果你在会议现场会稍微容易一些，因为你是按时间顺序看着事情发生的。但如果你稍后在 YouTube 上看这个，你可能会捕捉到——我的最爱是当我看到斯特凡·拉博维特（Stefan Labovate）时。
He's a big fan of Ramanujan numbers, as I am. And I think actually in your slide, you also had 42 and 1729. 1729 is one of my standard example numbers, yeah. Yeah, and so like I think in one of my talks once, I was like, oh, like I didn't know Stefan was like a huge fan. Anyways, it's just like for the, I don't know if it's super nerds or whatever, math nerds that just like numbers. It's very cool.
他是拉马努金数（Ramanujan numbers）的超级粉丝，就像我一样。我想实际上在你的幻灯片里，你也有 42 和 1729。1729 是我的标准示例数字之一，是的。是的，所以我想在我的某次演讲中，我曾说，哦，我不知道斯特凡竟然是个超级粉丝。不管怎样，对于那些超级书呆子，或者不管是哪种喜欢数字的数学书呆子来说。这真的很酷。
It's kind of like Easter eggs. If you watch enough talks, you start to pick up on things. Yeah, I definitely. Do you put things like that in your talks, Kate? I definitely put unexplained. You know, I don't bother to explain it while I'm talking, but there are examples for people who know. I do. 42 is usually there.
这有点像复活节彩蛋。如果你看足够多的演讲，你就会开始注意到一些事情。是的，我绝对会的。凯特，你在你的演讲中也会加入这样的小彩蛋吗？我绝对会加入未经解释的。你知道，我讲话时懒得去解释它，但对于懂的人来说，这些就是例子。我会的。42 通常都在那儿。
Absolutely. If you have to have a number. And there are certain things I don't put in. I used to do foo and bar, and now I don't. I have like a half hour on that. It's not the swearing. It's the darkness. It's a very dark humor.
绝对的。如果你必须得有一个数字的话。而且有些东西我不会放进去。我过去常常用 foo 和 bar，现在不用了。我为此花了半个小时。这不是说脏话的问题。这是黑暗的问题。这是一种非常黑色幽默。
But I think people say, wow, the same speakers are at the same conferences all the time, and we are. But it also then that calls back to where did we get our ideas from? I got my idea from watching someone else's talk, and it connected one thing to another thing in my brain and I went, oh, and then I got an idea. Cool. So what's going on for you for the rest of this year? I'm going to do nothing for August, like no thing. There's a hammock.
但我觉得人们会说，哇，同样的演讲者总是出现在同样的会议上，我们确实是。但这也让我们回想起，我们的创意是从哪里来的？我的创意来自于观看别人的演讲，它在我脑海里把一件事和另一件事连接起来，我说，哦，然后我得到了一个灵感。酷。那么你今年剩余时间有什么安排？我八月份什么都不做，真的什么都不做。那里有一张吊床。
I have some very thick books, fiction. Then in September, October, November, I have some private conferences, but I will also be in Norway for NDC Tech Town, where probably five of the speakers will have been here too, but all the rest of the attendees will be different. And that's what I like about going to Europe, is I get to see a different set of attendees. Great. Awesome.
我有一些很厚的书，是小说类的。然后从九月、十月、十一月开始，我有一些私人会议，但我也会去挪威参加 NDC Tech Town，在那里可能其中有五个演讲者也曾来到这里，但所有其他参会者都会是不同的人。这就是我喜欢去欧洲的原因，我可以见到一组不同的参会者。太棒了。太好了。
We will say thank you for being interviewed, and we will make sure that i think as your keynote as well as ben i think the keynotes typically come out uh first so by the time this airs because this might be part two of the cpp north live 2023 and we haven't mentioned we're on day three now so this is everything up till now you've heard was day two we're now the final morning we just finished watching jessica's keynote which was fantastic We hope to find her later and have a chat with her. But, yeah, thank you so much. And thank you for, you know, you're on the organizing committee of the board.
我们要说谢谢你接受采访，我们会确保——我想作为你的主题演讲以及本的主题演讲，主题演讲通常会首先发布——所以等这个节目播客播出时，因为这可能是 C++ 北方大会 2023 现场直播的第二部分，而我们还没有提到我们现在处于第三天，所以到目前为止你听到的所有内容都是第二天，我们现在是最后一天早晨，我们刚刚看完杰西卡的主题演讲，太棒了。我们希望稍后能找到她并和她聊聊。但是，是的，非常感谢。谢谢你（你知道的）作为董事会组织委员会的成员。
Thank you for putting on such an awesome conference. I'm so happy that we got Bloomberg as a last-minute gold sponsor because I, you know, have back channels to be able to hear updates. And it was, you know, it wasn't certain that there was going to be a third installation of this conference and mike was able to just announce that uh we're definitely going to be back you know details to be announced but there will be a cpp north 2024 anyway so thank you for all the hard work that you've done behind the scenes this conference has been awesome thank you for being here thank you for being part of it all right i'm going to hand the mic over to ben and we are going to interview kristin all right yeah, we are here at CPP North with Kristen Shaker. Kristen, how's the conference?
感谢你举办了如此棒的会议。我很高兴我们能在最后一刻拉到彭博社（Bloomberg）作为黄金赞助商，因为我（你知道的）有内部渠道能够听到最新消息。而且（你知道的）第三届会议是否能举办还不确定，迈克能够直接宣布（呃）我们绝对会回归（你知道的）细节待公布，但无论如何都会有 2024 年 C++ 北方大会。所以谢谢你在幕后所做的一切辛苦工作，这次会议太棒了。谢谢你来到这里，谢谢你成为其中的一部分。好的，我要把麦克风交给本，我们要采访克里斯滕。好的，是的，我们带着克里斯滕·谢克来到 C++ 北方大会。克里斯滕，会议感觉怎么样？
The conference is great. Tell us a bit about your C++ every day and your C++ journey. Okay, so my name's Kristen. I work on the C++ Libraries team at Google. We like to think of ourselves as, like, the stewards of the C++ portion of team at Google. We like to think of ourselves as the stewards of the C++ portion of the codebase, and in that aim, we strive to make it as
会议太棒了。给我们讲讲你的日常 C++ 以及你的 C++ 之旅吧。好的，我叫克里斯滕。我在谷歌的 C++ 库团队工作。我们喜欢把自己看作是团队中 C++ 部分的管家。我们喜欢把自己看作是谷歌代码库中 C++ 部分的管家，带着这个目标，我们努力使其尽可能地
maintainable, as usable, as reliable, as readable as possible. So I end up doing a lot of large-scale refactorings, trying to keep the codebase kind of pristine, optimized, and nice to use, and all that kind of stuff. I started writing C++ in college when I was 18.
可维护、可用、可靠、可读性强。所以我最终做了很多大规模的重构，试图让代码库保持一种崭新、优化、易用的状态，以及所有诸如此类的事情。我是在 18 岁上大学时开始编写 C++ 的。
They made all of the engineers take an intro to programming class, and I just loved it so much that I switched my major. And the whole curriculum of the University of Michigan is in C++. So I actually had a really solid foundation, and I thought I knew the language really well, and then I joined the C++ Libraries team at Google, and I realized I knew nothing. And I'm reminded of that fact every day.
他们让所有的工程师都修读一门编程导论课，我太喜欢它了，以至于我换了专业。密歇根大学的整个课程体系都是用 C++ 编写的。所以我实际上打下了非常坚实的基础，我以为我对这门语言非常了解，然后我加入了谷歌的 C++ 库团队，我意识到我什么都不懂。我每天都在被提醒这个事实。
I know slightly more than nothing now. I think that's a common experience. No matter how experienced you are at C++, you're often reminded that you don't know the things you don't know, a lot of things you don't know. Now, you're in the New York area, correct? Yes, I am. And you have a role in the New York C++ Meetup, so tell us about that. Yeah, so we're just like a group of individuals who are excited about C++
我现在知道的比一无所知稍微多一点。我想这是普遍的经历。无论你在 C++ 方面有多经验丰富，你经常会被提醒，你不知道那些你不知道的事情，有很多你不知道的事情。现在，你在纽约地区，对吧？是的，我是。你在纽约 C++ 聚会（New York C++ Meetup）中扮演了一个角色，给我们讲讲那个吧。是的，我们只是一群对 C++ 充满热情的个人
and love getting together to talk about it. We meet roughly once a month and we have some really world-renowned speakers come. We've had Titus Winters, David Sankal. We've had speakers from Facebook and Adobe. We've had events at MongoDB. And we've had Google speakers. So it's a really cool event.
并且喜欢聚在一起谈论它。我们大约一个月开会一次，我们会请到一些世界知名的演讲者。我们请过蒂图斯·温特斯（Titus Winters）、大卫·桑卡尔（David Sankal）。我们请过来自 Facebook 和 Adobe 的演讲者。我们在 MongoDB 举办过活动。我们还请过谷歌的演讲者。所以这是一个非常酷的活动。
You come, you mingle, you meet people in the industry, you make connections, and you really just have a good time. So if you are in the New York area, I would highly suggest you come to one of our meetups. You can find us. We are on meetup.com. NYC++ is the name of our organization. And yeah, we'd love to see you there.
你来这里，社交，结识行业内的人，建立联系，并且真的度过了一段美好的时光。所以如果你在纽约地区，我强烈建议你来参加我们的聚会。你可以找到我们。我们在 meetup.com 上。NYC++ 是我们组织的名称。是的，我们很期待在那里见到你。
So it's a monthly schedule? Is it a set? Like in Denver, we meet the first Thursday of the month. Do you have a set? No, it varies on hosting availability, I think, most of the time. Also, we like to accommodate speakers for when they're traveling into the city. So for example, we had Inbal Levy, who is based in Tel Aviv, come and we scheduled our meetup around her time in the city. So it's more variable, but the cadence is roughly once a month. Cool. So what talks have you enjoyed here at the conference? So I just got out of Matt Godbolt's
所以这是一个月度的日程安排？是固定的吗？就像在丹佛，我们在每月的第一个星期四开会。你们有固定的时间吗？没有，我觉得大部分时候这取决于场地的可用性。此外，我们喜欢为了配合那些来到这座城市的演讲者而调整时间。例如，我们曾邀请总部位于特拉维夫的因巴尔·利维（Inbal Levy）前来，我们围绕她在城里的时间安排了我们的聚会。所以它更有可变性，但频率大约是一个月一次。酷。那么你在这里的会议上听了哪些喜欢的演讲？我刚刚听完马特·戈德堡的
What's New in Compiler Explorer talk. I love learning about Compiler Explorer because it's 85% of my job. I do a ton of static analysis work for Google to execute these large-scale refactorings. We have to isolate very specific nodes in the abstract syntax tree. So I do a lot of work looking at clang output, and Compiler Explorer is a great tool for that. You can visualize the AST. You can visualize the control flow graph. You can test matchers in real time and see if you are correctly identifying and
《编译器浏览器有什么新变化》（What's New in Compiler Explorer）演讲。我喜欢了解编译器浏览器，因为这是我工作的 85% 的内容。我为谷歌做了大量的静态分析工作，以执行这些大规模的重构。我们必须隔离抽象语法树（AST）中的非常特定的节点。所以我做了很多查看 Clang 输出的工作，而编译器浏览器是实现这一目标的绝佳工具。你可以可视化 AST。你可以可视化控制流图。你可以实时测试匹配器，看看你是否正确识别和
isolating the nodes that you're looking for. So I love learning about Compiler Explorer. So I really enjoyed that talk. Awesome. Wait, wait. I also really enjoyed Connor's talk about combinators. It was a great talk. It was very entertaining. Yeah. And I learned a lot. Will you be going back to Google and turning everything into combinators? No. Turning some things into combinators? Thinking about combinators when you design and write code. Yes.
隔离了你在寻找的节点。所以我喜欢了解编译器浏览器。所以我真的很喜欢那场演讲。太棒了。等等，等等。我也非常喜欢康纳关于组合子（combinators）的演讲。那是一场很棒的演讲。非常有趣。是的。而且我学到了很多。你会回到谷歌然后把所有东西都变成组合子吗？不会。把一些东西变成组合子？在设计和编写代码时考虑组合子。是的。
Yeah, absolutely. That's a win. That's a win, folks. I use combinators a lot when I write Python for personal projects. There you go. But I don't use it a lot at work, to be honest. But I use the Python combinators a lot. At least I think they're combinators a lot when I write Python for personal projects. There you go. But I don't use it a lot at work, to be honest. But I use the Python combinators a lot. At least I think they're combinators. Like, you know, the map and filter and all that kind of stuff.
是的，绝对的。这是一个胜利。这是一个胜利，各位。当我为个人项目编写 Python 代码时，我经常使用组合子。给你。但在工作中我并不经常使用它，老实说。不过我经常使用 Python 组合子。至少我认为它们是组合子。当我为个人项目编写 Python 代码时。给你。但在工作中我并不经常使用它，老实说。不过我经常使用 Python 组合子。至少我认为它们是组合子。就像，你知道的，map 和 filter 以及所有诸如此类的事情。
I mean, there is a slide in my talk that talks about the Venn diagram of stuff. And in the larger sense, that maps and filters are combinators. They are functions that deal only in their arguments. Yeah. Is this your first time at this conference? Yes. Is it your first time in Canada? Or maybe you've probably been to Canada before,
我的意思是，我的演讲中有一张幻灯片讨论了事物的文氏图（Venn diagram）。从更广泛的意义上讲，map 和 filter 就是组合子。它们是只处理其参数的函数。是的。这是你第一次参加这个会议吗？是的。这是你第一次去加拿大吗？或者也许你以前可能去过加拿大，
being in New York. I almost went to McGill. So not my first time in Canada. I was here once when I was 18. Okay. But I don't know. I don't like to count anything that happened more than six years ago
既然你在纽约。我差点去了麦吉尔大学。所以这不是我第一次去加拿大。我 18 岁时来过这里一次。好的。但我不知道。我不喜欢把六年前发生的事情算作数，
because when I tend to think about that time, I just cringe a little bit. So I really only exist post-age 22, so I have not yet been to Canada in that time period. Sure, yeah. I mean, you'll reach a point in your life when you can look on that fondly, but it's true that you can look back at yourself, anyone can look back at themselves, and think how little they knew when they were at that age. I remember, anecdotally, I was in an interview once, and I was a huge fan of Excel, and they asked me,
因为当我倾向于去想那个时候的事情时，我只会感到有点尴尬。所以我真的只在 22 岁之后存在，所以在那段时间里我还没有去过加拿大。当然，是的。我的意思是，你会在人生中达到这样一个时刻，那时你可以满怀温情地回顾过去，但确实你可以回顾过去的自己，任何人都可以回顾过去的自己，并认为他们在那个年纪时知道得太少了。我记得，作为一个趣闻，我曾参加过一次面试，我当时是 Excel 的超级粉丝，他们问我，
so on a scale of 1 to 10, where are you? And I said, well, you know, I don't want to say there's no room for growth. But, you know, so I said, you know, I kind of want to say 9, but also kind of 10. I didn't even know what a pivot table was at the time, folks. I retrospectively should have been a 0. I knew how to make graphs, and that was it. But you don't know what a pivot table was at the time, folks. I retrospectively should have been a zero. I knew how to make graphs and that was it. But you don't know what you don't know. It's a hallmark of expertise that you're acutely aware of how much you don't know, I think.
那么在 1 到 10 的等级中，你给自己打几分？我说，嗯，你知道，我不想说没有成长空间。但是，你知道，所以我说，你知道，我既想说 9，又有点想说 10。各位，我当时甚至不知道什么是数据透视表（pivot table）。我事后看来应该给自己打 0 分。我当时只知道怎么制作图表，仅此而已。但各位，你当时甚至不知道什么是数据透视表。我事后看来应该给自己打零分。我当时只知道怎么制作图表，仅此而已。但你不知道你不知道什么。专业知识的一个标志就是你敏锐地意识到自己有多少不知道的事情，我认为。
I got this quote from Ben. The larger your island of knowledge, the longer your shore of ignorance. We love that from Ben. I didn't make that up. I can't remember where I got that from, but someone said that first and it was not me. It wasn't in the C++ community. It was just someone I found online. So here's a question. I believe Titus, when I was chatting with him last year about the 2022 version of this conference, he mentioned your name as a
我从本那里听到了这句话。你的知识岛屿越大，你无知的海岸线就越长。我们很喜欢本的这句话。这不是我编的。我不记得我是从哪儿听来的了，但有人最先说了这句话，那不是我。它不是在 C++ 社区里。它只是我在网上发现的某个人说的。所以这里有一个问题。我相信蒂图斯去年和我聊到 2022 年版的这次会议时，他提到了你的名字，说你是一个
potential speaker. You didn't speak then. I don't think you're speaking this year. Can we expect to see Kristen Shaker giving a talk at CPP North 2024 as Mike just mentioned this morning because of Bloomberg being a gold sponsor, we're going to have an audition can we expect to see you on stage there, putting you on the spot a little bit I mean you run a meetup
潜在的演讲者。你当时没有演讲。我想你今年也没有演讲。我们能期待看到克里斯滕·谢克在 2024 年 C++ 北方大会上发表演讲吗？正如迈克今天早上刚提到的那样，由于彭博社成为黄金赞助商，我们将有一场试讲，我们能期待看到你出现在那里的舞台上吗？有点把你架在火上烤了。我的意思是，你经营一个聚会
or at least you co-run a meetup so I assume you are a speaker there at times it depends on whether or not CppCon accepts my abstract and I am forced to actually write the talk. Great. Well, you know, if it's a good abstract, I'm sure they will. Once it's written, I have no qualms about giving it at subsequent conferences.
或者至少你联合经营一个聚会，所以我假设你有时会在那里演讲。这取决于 CppCon 是否接受我的摘要，而我被迫去真正把这个演讲写出来。太好了。嗯，你知道，如果这是一个好的摘要，我确信他们会接受的。一旦写好了，我在随后的会议上做这个演讲没有任何心理负担。
I don't actually know which talk you submit to CppCon. Normally I'm on the program committee, but this year they, I got the email and then it stayed in my inbox for a while. And then when I finally got around to it, to signing up, then I got an email from Chris saying, you know, we're just wrapping up. And I look back at the date and it had been like five weeks since, so I was a bit late on that one. Can we get a preview of this potentially going to be accepted because i i tell you what would this be your first talk at like a c++ conference i gave a lightning talk on how to uh leverage compiler explorer to i like look at the ast and isolate specific lines of code and this talk would be about how to write your first clank tidy that i would like to see that talk because Clang Tidy is one of those things,
我实际上不知道你向 CppCon 提交了哪个演讲。通常我是节目委员会的成员，但今年他们——我收到了邮件，然后它在我的收件箱里呆了一段时间。然后当我终于腾出时间来注册时，我收到了克里斯（Chris）发来的邮件，（你知道的）说我们马上就要结束了。我回头看了一下日期，发现距离发出邮件已经过去大约五个星期了，所以我在那件事上有点迟了。我们能先睹为快这个演讲是否有被接受的可能吗？因为我——我告诉你，这会是你在 C++ 会议上的第一次演讲吗？我做过一个关于如何利用编译器浏览器来查看 AST 并隔离特定代码行的闪电演讲，而这个演讲将是关于如何编写你的第一个 Clang Tidy。我很想看那个演讲，因为 Clang Tidy 是那种
like it's been on my list of things to get around. It'd be super useful just to have an on-ramp into writing your own Clang Tidy check. Yeah, so the idea would be how to, like it would be an overview of what the AST is. It's like super information-rich data structure that we have as part of the compilation process, how you can leverage creation of that tree to isolate and alter pieces of your code to be
一直在我的待办事项列表上的东西。拥有一个编写你自己的 Clang Tidy 检查的切入点会超级有用。是的，所以这个想法将是如何——就像它将是对 AST 是什么的一个概述。这是一个超级信息丰富的 数据结构，它是我们编译过程的一部分，你如何利用该树的创建来隔离和修改代码片段，使其
more idiomatic or more performant, and how you can run that tooling over translation units and actually generate the edits in real time. I'm a big user of Clang Tidy because it's part of the CI process, right? It's really important for quality. But I feel like if there were a lower barrier to entry to actually every company writing their own Clang Tidy checks, like the individual little things that you want your code base to look like, that would be great. Yeah, the AST matches are notoriously opaque
更具地道风格（idiomatic）或性能更高，以及你如何对翻译单元运行该工具并实时生成编辑。我是 Clang Tidy 的大用户，因为它是 CI 流程的一部分，对吧？它对质量真的很重要。但我觉得，如果能有一个更低的门槛，让每个公司都能真正编写他们自己的 Clang Tidy 检查——比如你希望你的代码库看起来的那些个别的小事——那将是太棒了。是的，AST 匹配器是出了名的晦涩难懂，
and there's limited documentation on it. So it'd be really nice to just have like an end-to-end user story. Here is how you start from scratch. Here is how you actually get to the point where you can run it on real code. Just like a video explaining that. That was kind of the idea, the impetus for the talk. So we'll see if it gets accepted.
并且关于它的文档有限。所以如果能有一个端到端的真实用户故事会非常棒。这里是如何从零开始。这里是如何真正达到可以在真实代码上运行它的地步。就像一个解释这一点的视频。这就是这个演讲的想法、推动力。所以我们要看看它是否能被接受。
Cool. Well, if it doesn't get accepted in one conference, I hope to see it at another future conference. Yeah. Okay. And I will put this talk whenever it shows up at a conference and whenever it shows up on YouTube. It'll be in the show notes. It might be, you know, three months from now.
酷。好吧，如果它没有被一个会议接受，我希望在另一个未来的会议上看到它。是的。好的。每当这个演讲出现在某个会议上，每当它出现在 YouTube 上时，我都会把这个演讲放进去。它会出现在节目说明中。这可能是，（你知道的）三个月之后。
But I've got a little Python script that checks my unlinked links so that they're never, you know, sometimes it takes a while. But for the listeners, if you just started listening in 2025, guaranteed there's a link to this from a YouTube recording from some conference that happened in the past. Absolutely. All right. Well, thanks a lot, Kristen. You're welcome. Awesome. conference that happened in the past. Absolutely. All right. Well, thanks a lot, Kristen. You're welcome. Awesome. Enjoy the rest of the conference. And we hope to see you here next year. Yeah. And let's go to lunch.
但我有一个小 Python 脚本来检查我的未链接链接，这样它们就永远不会，（你知道的）有时这需要一些时间。但对于听众来说，如果你在 2025 年才开始收听，绝对可以保证这里有一个来自过去某场会议的 YouTube 录像的链接。绝对的。好的。非常谢谢你，克里斯滕。不客气。太棒了。过去某场会议的录像的链接。绝对的。好的。非常谢谢你，克里斯滕。不客气。太棒了。享受会议剩下的时间吧。我们希望明年还能在这里见到你。是的。我们去吃午饭吧。
We'll figure something out. All right. We're here. Almost the end of day three, 2023 CPP North. We're about to interview the third keynote that took place this morning. I'm going to hand the mic over to Ben and let him do the interview. Hi, this is Jessica Kerr, and she's here at CPP North. Jessica, how's the conference been for you? Oh, it's been lovely. This is like, it's a three-day conference, and it's the third day,
我们会想出点什么的。好的。我们到了。几乎是 2023 年 C++ 北方大会第三天的尾声。我们即将采访今天上午进行的主题演讲的第三位演讲者。我要把麦克风交给本，让他来做这次采访。嗨，这是杰西卡·克尔，她来到了 C++ 北方大会。杰西卡，这次会议对你来说感觉怎么样？哦，真是太棒了。这就像是，这是一个为期三天的会议，现在已经是第三天了，
and I'm not completely sick of it yet. And nobody else is either, which is unusual for conferences these days so you're better known outside of c++ than in the c++ community so just tell us a bit about what you do and how it is you you happen to be at the c++ conference um right what do i do i talk about software to software engineers i'm actually really into systems thinking and how our software is a complex system that we're part of. And you work at Honeycomb. I do. I work at Honeycomb. And the reason I work at Honeycomb is Honeycomb is an observability tool. And observability gives us, as developers, a tool for seeing into the systems that we create, not just the code,
而且我还没有完全对它感到厌烦。其他人也没有，这在如今的会议中是很少见的。所以你在 C++ 社区之外比在 C++ 社区内更知名，所以给我们讲讲你的工作，以及你是怎么碰巧来到这个 C++ 会议的。嗯，对，我是做什么的？我向软件工程师谈论软件。我其实对系统思考非常感兴趣，以及我们的软件如何成为我们身处其中的复杂系统。你在 Honeycomb 工作。是的。我在 Honeycomb 工作。我之所以在 Honeycomb 工作，是因为 Honeycomb 是一个可观测性（observability）工具。可观测性为我们作为开发者提供了一个深入了解我们所创建的系统的工具，不仅仅是代码，
but the actual running systems in production. And that's kind of an amazing way for us to get better at working with systems. So my thing is that as software developers, we have a unique opportunity to play in these complex distributed systems that we also have some control over and we have the ability to make them tell us what's going on. So I think we are uniquely positioned to get good at working in complex systems. And that's something the world needs right now, inside and outside of software. Absolutely. So how did you come to be speaking at a C++ conference?
而是生产环境中实际运行的系统。对于我们提升处理系统的工作能力来说，这算是一种了不起的方式。所以我的观点是，作为软件开发人员，我们拥有独特的机遇，可以在这些复杂的分布式系统中发挥作用，同时我们对它们也有一定的控制权，并且我们有能力让它们告诉我们发生了什么。所以我认为我们处于独特的有利位置，能够擅长在复杂系统中工作。这也是当今世界在软件内部和外部都迫切需要的东西。绝对的。那么你是怎么来到一个 C++ 会议上做演讲的？
Oh, Eamon emailed me and asked me if I wanted to. Well, great. I may secretly, I'm the former program chair and Jessica may secretly be one of my favorite speakers of all time. I've seen many of your talks.
哦，埃蒙（Eamon）给我发了电子邮件，问我想不想来。嗯，太棒了。我可能暗地里——我是前任节目主席，而杰西卡可能暗地里是我有史以来最喜欢的演讲者之一。我看过你的很多演讲。
I've also, we'll link in the show notes. I'll figure out how to do it because you've been, I think you actually have a couple of podcasts yourself now we were chatting earlier, but you've been a long time guest on many, very, very much more popular than our podcasts. I think you were on changelog and they have, I don't know how many thousands of listeners, but, uh, I can't keep, I can't keep track. I just always say yes, because, um, I never really know what I think until somebody asks me so i find out
我还会，我们会在节目说明中附上链接。我会弄清楚怎么做，因为你一直是——我想你实际上现在自己也有好几个播客，我们之前聊天时谈过，但你一直是许多播客的长期嘉宾，这些播客比我们的播客受欢迎得多得多。我想你曾上过 Changelog，他们有，我不知道有多少万听众，但是，我记不过来，我总是说“好”，因为，嗯，直到有人问我之前，我从来不真的知道自己在想什么，所以我发现
tell us more i mean we were both in the keynote this morning i absolutely fantastic i'm you know and also your lightning talk last night like it was just i was i was watching the lightning talk and i was like this is gonna take a turn i was like did it did he steal all his ideas and then the turn was just anyways we'll link the lightning talk it was so amazing and i was like holy smokes like you bring like a whole other like style and just, anyways, we'll link the lightning talk. It was so amazing. And I was like, holy smokes, like you bring like a whole other like style and just energy. Anyways, lightning talk was amazing. But tell us a bit about your keynote.
跟我们多讲讲——我的意思是，我们今天早上都在主题演讲现场，绝对太棒了。我（你知道的）还有你昨晚的闪电演讲，就像是——我当时在看闪电演讲，我心里想，这要来个大反转了，我当时想，他是把所有的创意都偷来的吗？然后反转就是——不管怎样，我们会附上闪电演讲的链接，太惊人了，我当时想，天哪，你带来了完全不同的另一种风格和能量。不管怎样，闪电演讲太棒了。但给我们讲讲你的主题演讲吧。
It was absolutely fantastic. But yeah. Thanks about the lightning talk. I worked hard on that one over the last couple of weeks. But my keynote this morning was about the difference between writing code
绝对太棒了。但是，是的。谢谢你对闪电演讲的夸奖。在过去的几周里，我为那个下了很大功夫。但我今天早上的主题演讲是关于编写代码
and getting anything done. Like really making changes in a software system, which is part of a larger system and how much more work that is and how much more social work that is. Because we think of software change as a technical problem,
与真正把事情做完之间的区别。比如在软件系统中真正做出改变——这是更大系统的一部分——这需要多少更多的工作，以及这需要多少更多的社交工作。因为我们认为软件变更是技术问题，
but in any company bigger than one engineering team, it's mostly a social problem. Yeah, it was a great keynote and um i felt very complimentary to to mine which is great whenever you come to a conference and other talks can play off yours you know i talked about technical the technical problems are changing you talked about the social problems so i'd like to ask you you know as one speaker to another what's your process for making a talk? Okay, so anymore, at some point, the organizers really want a title or abstract.
但在任何大于一个工程团队的公司里，它主要都是一个社交问题。是的，这是一个很棒的主题演讲，而且我感觉它与我的演讲非常互补，每当你来到一个会议，并且其他演讲能与你的演讲相互呼应时，这真的很棒，我谈论的是技术问题，而你谈论的是社交问题，所以我想问你，你知道，作为同行演讲者，你制作演讲的流程是怎样的？好吧，再往后，在某个时刻，组织者确实想要一个标题或摘要。
And then I tell them what I want to have talked about at this moment, what I want to talk about right then. And then... I like the way you put it, what I want to have talked about. Like, it's good to have done the talk. Exactly.
然后我告诉他们我此时想谈论什么，我当时就想讲什么。然后……我喜欢你的表述方式，我当时想谈论什么。就像，做完这个演讲感觉很好。没错。
I'm very happy right now, yeah. But this was a new keynote. But I found that I was really excited about talking about the difference between coding and getting things done. And then last week, I had to sit down and actually start writing the top. But I didn't want to because I wanted to work on this blog post about what the engineering team at Honeycomb has been doing with this big re-architecting project that they've been working on. And then I realized that I could use that as an example in this keynote. Nice. That is very fortuitous that the stars aligned. The thing that you wanted to work on, you discovered,
我现在非常高兴，是的。但这一个新的主题演讲。但我发现我真的很兴奋能够谈论编码与把事情做完之间的区别。然后上周，我不得不坐下来开始真正写这个演讲。但我不想写，因为我想写这篇博客文章，关于 Honeycomb 的工程团队一直在用他们正在进行的大型重新架构项目做些什么。然后我意识到我可以在这个主题演讲中把那个当作一个例子。太棒了。群星闪耀，真是太巧了。你想做的那件事，你发现，
is the thing I can work on in preparation for this keynote. Exactly, exactly. I brought the pipes together in that way. And that made it easier to work on the keynote. But still, it takes a crunch takes a crunch a deadline to actually bring these creative things together so fortunately i i spoke on the last day of the conference so i had the first two days to write it right oh okay so you are one of these people who goes up to the wire i mean i i try to get my slides done a couple of weeks ahead of time and then iterate them.
正是我为了准备这个主题演讲可以拿来用的东西。没错，没错。我以那种方式把两头连通了起来。这使得编写主题演讲变得容易多了。不过，要真正把这些有创意的东西组合在一起，仍然需要经历紧凑的赶工、一个截止日期。所以幸运的是，我在会议的最后一天发言，所以我有前两天的时间来写它。哦，原来你是那种死线战士。我的意思是——我尽量在几周前就把幻灯片做好，然后进行迭代。
But I still go up to the wire with changes. I mean, I saw what I think was a photo of the aforementioned Eamon, who is now the program chair, in your talk. And I'm pretty sure that that wasn't a photo from taken in the past. It looks like you took that photo at this conference. Yeah, like today. Oh, no, no, no. Like about 10 minutes before the keynote started, I found Eamon. So that photo was actually taken from the podium where my laptop was already set up
但我还是会赶在最后一刻做修改。我的意思是，我看到了我之前提到的埃蒙的照片，他现在是节目主席，出现在你的演讲中。我很确定那不是过去拍的照片。看起来你是在这次会议上拍的那张照片。是的，就像今天。哦，不，不，不。就像在主题演讲开始前大约 10 分钟，我找到了埃蒙。所以那张照片实际上是从我的笔记本电脑已经架好的讲台那里拍的
and went into the presentation. That is, because I saw that he had the beard, and this is the first time. We're giving a lot of description to Eamon here. Our program chair, we love you, Eamon. Thanks for the work you did. He has a yellow shirt today. He has a yellow shirt today. He had a yellow shirt today. But it was the beard I was like, I'm pretty sure this was taken at the conference.
然后就开始了演讲。也就是说，因为我看到他留了胡子，而且这是第一次。我们在这里对埃蒙进行了很多描述。我们的项目主席，我们爱你，埃蒙。谢谢你所做的工作。他今天穿了一件黄衬衫。他今天穿了一件黄衬衫。他今天穿了一件黄衬衫。但让我注意到的是胡子，我当时想，我确信这张照片是在会议上拍的。
And so you were editing your keynote, like, not just at the conference, but minutes before you're giving it. That is, you know, this is like Tony's talks. Tony had a talk a few years ago where one of his slides was a picture of him on the stage showing the slide. And then it like recursed. So it was this picture of him showing the slide with the picture of him in the slide. Wow. Wow. I'm still not sure how he pulled that off.
所以你一直在修改你的主题演讲，不仅是在会议期间，而是在你演讲前几分钟。你知道，这就像托尼的演讲。托尼几年前有过一次演讲，他的幻灯片之一就是他在舞台上展示该幻灯片的照片。然后它就递归了。所以那是他在幻灯片中展示带有他自己照片的幻灯片的照片。哇。哇。我还是不太明白他是怎么做到的。
This is what separates, you know, the aspiring speakers to the keynote speakers is being able to, you able to edit that late and still pull off what looks like it. And I'm like, wait, this is so polished. What separates those aspiring speakers from those keynote speakers is time. It's that I've done this a bunch, and so it's not scary. And I know that in two days I can pull it together because I've been working on it in my head for weeks. Right, right. So I have the same thing. Yeah, I've been thinking about it forever.
这就是有抱负的演讲者与主题演讲者之间的区别，即能够如此晚地进行修改，并且仍然能呈现出看起来如此完美的效果。而我想，等等，这太精炼了。那些有抱负的演讲者与那些主题演讲者之间的区别在于时间。是因为我这样做过很多次，所以并不觉得可怕。而且我知道我能在两天内把它整理好，因为我已经在脑海里琢磨了好几个星期了。对，对。所以我也一样。是的，我一直在考虑这件事。
And then it's time to just like make it concrete. Condense it. Yeah. And then so I made an adequate version of the slides, talked through the talk, stopped and was like, nope, these are in the wrong order. Nope, I need this right here. And I don't know how it's going to go until I vocalize it. Right. Yeah, so talk through it, get the slide deck enough for that.
然后是时候把它具体化了。精简它。是的。然后我做了一个足够版本的幻灯片，顺着讲了一遍，停下来想，不对，这些顺序反了。不对，我这里需要这个。在把它们说出来之前，我不知道进展会怎样。对。是的，所以把它讲出来，把幻灯片准备到差不多。
And then if I have time, go through it again. I was able to go through the conclusion twice. The conclusion is the hard bit. So you, sort of maybe as a last question, because we've got only a few minutes before the final keynote that is going to wrap this conference.
然后如果我有时间，再过一遍。我有机会把结论部分过了两遍。结论是最难的部分。所以你，也许作为最后一个问题，因为在即将为这次会议画上句号的最后一场主题演讲之前，我们只剩下几分钟了。
You have, as Mike mentioned, as he introduced you, spoken, keynoted at many different conferences in many different communities. And this is your first time to a C++ conference, and definitely this conference isn't necessarily representative of all different C++ conferences. But my two kind of questions are, what are your overall honest thoughts of the community here?
正如迈克在介绍你时所提到的，你曾在许多不同的社区、许多不同的会议上发表过主题演讲。这是你第一次参加C++会议，而且这次会议绝对不一定代表所有不同的C++会议。但我的两个问题是，你对这里的社区有什么整体的、真实的看法？
But also, is there anything that you've seen in other communities that you think we could borrow from that would be good to incorporate to make this conference be more inclusive? Definitely, I think we're doing our best, but if you look around in the audience, we definitely could do better in terms of attracting different folks to this conference. So you've been to so many different communities and seen different flavors and whatnot. Just, yeah, interested to get your thoughts of maybe what we're doing, how you feel about the conference, when, and what we could do in the future. I think the conference is fantastic.
还有，你在其他社区看到过什么你认为我们可以借鉴、并很好地融入进来以使这次会议更具包容性的东西吗？毫无疑问，我认为我们已经尽力了，但如果你环顾观众席，在吸引不同人群参加这次会议方面，我们确实还可以做得更好。所以你参加过那么多不同的社区，见过不同的风格等等。只是，是的，有兴趣了解你的想法，比如我们在做什么，你对这次会议的感受，以及我们未来可以做些什么。我认为这次会议棒极了。
I think one reason it's day three and I'm not exhausted, I haven't seen any alcohol at this conference. I have a non-alcoholic beer in my hand right now. I love those. Years of practice getting relaxed by beer. This stuff totally works. It's super family friendly. There like parent rooms there's a prayer room the bathrooms have been converted into all gender bathrooms which still makes them mostly men's bathrooms because
我认为这是第三天而我还没有感到筋疲力尽的原因之一是，我在这次会议上没有看到任何酒精。我手里现在正拿着一杯无酒精啤酒。我喜欢那种。多年来通过啤酒放松的练习。这东西真的很管用。它对家庭非常友好。那里有家长休息室，有一个祈祷室，洗手间被改造成了全性别洗手间，这仍然使得它们大多是男士洗手间，因为
it that's the the ratio but there are many uh really interesting women here and several of the speakers. So I suspect the diversity level is probably better than the C++ community as a whole. I think that's true, yeah. Yeah, yeah. This is a group of people who, there's a ton of people with PhDs. They are really smart. And they can solve really hard problems, such as writing code in C++ that doesn't have undefined behavior. Well, I mean, come on now.
那是比例问题，但这里有很多非常有趣的女性和几位演讲者。所以我猜测多样性水平可能比整个C++社区要好。我认为确实如此，是的。是的，是的。这是一群人，有大量拥有博士学位的人。他们真的很聪明。他们能够解决非常难的问题，比如编写没有未定义行为的C++代码。好吧，我是说，拜托。
That's a bit of a tall order. Yes, totally. And the talks are, like, super technical, but also well-researched and interesting. And I've learned a bunch about the language, which is really fun. But it's fun to see a bunch of people who are excited to learn more about a language and also care about people. We want to do this better. And it's not about I want to be the best. It's really about everyone is here to help other people as well as themselves which feels great there's a lot that i'll take away this to
那有点要求太高了。是的，完全是。而且演讲非常技术性，但同时也经过充分研究且引人入胜。我学到了很多关于这门语言的知识，这真的很有趣。但看到一群人兴奋地想要更多地了解一门语言同时也关心他人，这很有趣。我们想要把它做得更好。这并不是关于我想成为最好的。这真的是关于每个人都在这里帮助别人以及他们自己，这感觉棒极了，我将从这次
this conference and from this conference and recommend in other communities great yes and i totally agree you know when i get up on stage and give a talk i try to give talks that have nuggets of information, actionable things. I don't want people to come away from the talk thinking, well, you know, that was Ben and he does that stuff, but I could never. I want people to think, there's some things I could use, right? I can get there too. Yeah, and your talk was about having the unreasonable goal of perfection, of no bugs when the software leaves your laptop.
会议中带走很多东西，并在其他社区推荐它们。太棒了，是的，我完全同意，当我走上舞台发表演讲时，我尽量提供包含信息金块、可付诸行动的事情的演讲。我不希望人们离开演讲时想，嗯，你知道，那是本，他会做那些事，但我永远做不到。我希望人们认为，有些事情我可以用，对吧？我也能做到。是的，你的演讲是关于追求完美的无理目标，即当软件离开你的笔记本电脑时没有bug。
Right. And that is a useful goal to aim for. Don't expect it of yourself. Totally, yeah. I mean, I've made many mistakes, right? I still do. Some human, I think it was Matt Godbolt said today. Some human.
对。这是一个值得追求的有用目标。不要对自己抱有这种期望。完全是，是的。我的意思是，我犯过很多错误，对吧？我仍然在犯。有些人，我想马特·戈德博特（Matt Godbolt）今天说过。有些人。
That is a great description of Matt Godbolt. Some human. I think it was Matt Godbolt said today. Some human. That is a great description of Matt Godbolt. Some human. Some human. I think it was Matt Gobbled. Just to clarify that he wasn't a computer or something. He said, no human can write correct Siebel's Plus code. Was it correct? Something about no human can write Siebel's Plus code without undefined behavior.
那是对马特·戈德博特很好的描述。有些人。我想马特·戈德博特今天说过。有些人。那是对马特·戈德博特很好的描述。有些人。有些人。我想马特·戈德博特说过。只是为了澄清他不是一台计算机什么的。他说，没有人类能编写正确的C++代码。是正确的吗？关于没有人类能编写没有未定义行为的C++代码的事情。
Meaning, use your linters. Right. Use your Clang Tidy and your Sonar and your other tools. Yeah. It's a socio-technical system, and we aren't in it alone. Exactly. Awesome. Well, I'll finish by saying thank you so much for coming and speaking.
意思是，使用你的代码检查工具。对。使用你的Clang Tidy、Sonar和其他工具。是的，这是一个社会技术系统，我们并不孤单。完全正确。太棒了。好吧，我最后想说，非常感谢你的光临和演讲。
I can't wait for your talk to go online for not just the folks here that saw it, but the Internet to see it, because I think the talk is great in general. But the way you ended it just sort of on that. Don't just think about the code. Think about the impact. And also, like, I'm saying this, but if you feel this way about your job, like, that's totally valid and totally legitimate. And there's different ways to have, you know, impact. Sometimes it's through your job, your code. But anyways, the note you ended on was just so fantastic.
我迫不及待地想让你的演讲上线，不仅是给这里看到它的观众，也是给互联网上的所有人看，因为我认为这个演讲总体上很棒。但你结束的方式恰好切入这一点。不要只考虑代码。要考虑影响。而且，就像，我在这么说，但如果你对你的工作有这种感觉，那完全是合情合理的。而且有不同的方式来产生影响。有时是通过你的工作、你的代码。无论如何，你结束时的那个观点真是太棒了。
And one of my favorite talks of yours. There we go. We'll edit that in post. But yeah, thank you so much for coming. And hopefully we'll run into each other maybe at this conference in the future at another conference. It was so awesome to have you at this conference. I tell you that the very ending of my keynote was actually a callback to how Mike opened the conference on Monday. He said, uh, patience, curiosity, and love. That's what we need. And, and I was really pleased to get to call back to that. Yeah. It was so awesome. Yep. Yeah. I did notice that. So anyway, thanks very much. Thank you. Enjoy the last talk. Hopefully, hopefully that's not the one that puts you over the edge. Uh, but yeah, thanks so much. Thank you to all of the speakers and attendees that agreed
这也是我最喜欢的你的演讲之一。这就对了。我们会在后期剪辑中处理它。但是，是的，非常感谢你的到来。希望我们未来可能会在这次会议或另一场会议上再次相遇。很高兴你能来到这次会议。我告诉你，我主题演讲的最后其实是对迈克周一如何开启会议的回应。他说，呃，耐心、好奇心和爱。这就是我们所需要的。而且，我真的很高兴能回应这一点。是的。太棒了。是的。我注意到了这一点。所以无论如何，非常感谢。谢谢。享受最后的演讲。希望，希望那不是那个让你崩溃的演讲。呃，但是，是的，非常感谢。感谢所有同意
to be interviewed over the last two episodes. These episodes were a blast to record and edit. Be sure to check your show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything
在过去两集中接受采访的演讲者和与会者。录制和编辑这些节目非常有趣。请务必查看你的播客应用程序中或访问ADSPthepodcast.com上的节目说明，以获取我们在今天的节目中提到的任何内容的链接
we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave questions, comments, and thoughts. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下问题、评论和想法。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高质量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息 sprinkles（点缀）的混乱。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子来发表评论。